tout du texte non becker et voilà
n'oubliez pas de sourire comme chaque
semaine depuis plusieurs mois la troupe
d'agde à rester et se retrouvent pour
répéter la comédie musicale aux
commandes a aidé une jeune fille de 16
ans qui s'est attaqué à l'écriture et la
mise en scène du livret d'un spectacle
ambitieux l'une heures 45
j'ai fait des recherches et s'est basé
sur des faits réels
en fait donc l'histoire se passe six
siècles avant jésus-christ dans une
véritable cité grecque avec de
véritables personnages d'autres qui ont
été inventés dans le cocon familial
slovan sa soeur aînée et le reste de la
famille ont mis toutes leurs forces pour
en faire une belle aventure humaine
riche d'enseignements on a appris
énormément de choses c'est vrai que au
début mais on savait pas trop comment
monter le budget comment faire pour
avoir des demandes de subventions pour
entrer dans le milieu associatif tout ça
est donc
donc c'est vrai que ça nous a appris
énormément de choses aussi de ça nous a
appris à gérer un groupe de jeunes
24 comédiens chanteurs danseurs sous
l'oeil bienveillant d'adultes qui assure
costumes décors intendance et technique
arrive aujourd'hui au terme de ce projet
chacun a apporté son savoir-faire juste
participe à la comédie musicale en tant
que compositeur donc ça idée qui m'a
demandé de participer donc pour l'aider
dans ce projet et donc ensuite lors de
la répartition des rôles à me demander
si ça m'intéressait de faire ce rôle et
ben je dis que oui
aujourd'hui la comédie musicale et
sponsorisé en faire pâlir plus d'un un
cd des chansons a été enregistré les
avant-premières se succèdent et cinq
représentations sont prévues plusieurs
villes du département pourront voir à
galeristes et c'est bien ce qu'on fait
parce que et pas beaucoup de deux
spectacles de jeunes et ça montre qu'on
peut faire faire des choses même étant
adolescent et à idées garde les pieds
sur terre de cette expérience menée de
main de maître
elle attend bien sûr la reconnaissance
du public mais pour elle l' aventure
humaine est déjà une réussite